this is Hercules he's supposed to be
walking in a nice straight line but
actually he's just monkeying around
Hercules is one of two chimps helping
scientists understand the origins of
human walking this is what humans look
like when they walk to keep track of the
body's movements research has stuck
markers on specific points of their
subjects and trace their position and
this is Hercules his colleague Leo
taking a stroll clearly pretty different
his human counterpart chimps swing their
hips much more than humans when they
walk by tracing the markers the
researchers were able to analyze these
differences when humans walk we swing
our ribs in the opposite direction to
our hips which helps us to save energy
from looking at their skeletons chimps
torsos appear to be too rigid to make
this movement possible but surprisingly
Hercules and Leo's bodies do twist a
little as they walk you can see their
ribs move in the same direction as their
hips but they are cancelling out some of
the motion these two walking styles may
still seem pretty different but if you
hold the hip still you can see that the
ribs are still compensating by the same
amount in both humans and chimps these
chimp results imply that human ancestors
like Australopithecus might also have
walked more dynamically than we
previously thought who would have
thought that Hercules strutting his
stuff on a catwalk could teach us so
much
you